[MUSIC PLAYING]
So we've got our
basic Shiny navbarPage.
And pretty much, any
navbarPage that you've seen,
you'll probably notice that
you're constricted to the fact
that each one of these tab links
has to link to content inside
of that page.
So we haven't
really provided you
with a way to officially provide
another link here that maybe
links to some external website.
Or what if you wanted to
have a right-aligned nav
item that links to a login
page or something like that?
Historically, there's been
no way to do this officially
with Shiny.
So I've seen people come
up with pretty crazy hacks
to make this possible,
which was part
of the motivation for doing
this in the first place.
But bslib provides this
new API, essentially,
that replaces tabPanel and
navbarPage and navbarMenu--
the basic building
blocks that you
may have used to create a
navbarPage or a tabsetPanel
or something like that.
So with the new
interface, it's called--
instead of tabPanel,
you say nav.
We give it a title,
give it some content.
There's also a nav_item.
It basically just takes whatever
you give it and places it
directly in that nav heading.
So you could do something
like provide a hyperlink
to Shiny's GitHub
page or wherever
you want to provide a link to.
There's actually also ways of
using this to include something
like text input box, which
would allow you to implement
something like a search
feature in your Shiny app
where somebody could type in.
In the navbar at the top, they
could search for something.
And then you could wire
that up to some server logic
to show something as people are
typing, something like that.
There's also this
nav_spacer where
it's like the name suggests.
It just adds spacing in between
one set of nav_nav_items
and another set
of nav_nav_items.
So by putting the
nav-spacer here,
this will basically
left-align all of this--
all of these, like the a and the
b and the Shiny external link.
And then it will write a line--
this nav_menu--
that has other links
to more content within
the page and then another
nav_item to link to some
other external content.
And this is a fancy way
of reducing duplication
for this particular example,
where this nav_item's function
will return a list of
these nav_items essentially
so that I can use
this rlang splicing
operator to essentially splice
in the list of nav_items
into this navbarPage.
There's also another argument
to navbar that allows you to--
like, if you have
some content that you
want to show regardless of
what nav_item is selected
in a navbarPage, you can use--
there's a header and a footer
to say, always show this content
above or below the
other content that
is dependent on whatever
tab is selected.
So I'm using that to also show
these other functions that
can consume a
collection of nav_items
called navs_tab, navs_pill.
So these two
functions essentially
replace tabsetPanel for
creating that basic tab look
or also with pills.
And there's also variants on
these called navs_tab_card
and navs_pill_card,
which I'll just show you
how these actually look.
So here's the first
navs_tab here.
So this is like the kind
of classic tabsetPanel
look that we're used
to seeing everywhere
with the ability to flip through
the tab a and tab b content.
I also have this
Shiny link here,
which will take me to
Shiny's GitHub page
as well as the
right-aligned menu
with the other external
link and some other content.
So I've taken the same nav_items
essentially and placed them
inside of this page_navbar
to get the top level a and b
content.
So I can flip back
and forth here.
And then this is
the footer content
with those other
variants for rendering
a collection of nav_items.
So here's the navs_tab,
the navs_pill.
I do like this a little
bit generally better
than the basic tabsetPanel
look in general.
But I think part of the reason
why tabsetPanel doesn't always
look great is the
fact that there
is no padding between this
content here and the border.
And there's also-- the
border doesn't extend
around the content either.
So it looks like there's
content floating in space.
And it's also smashed together.
So that's why we've
provided this navs_tab_card
and navs_pill_card to add
some border around all
of the content and add some
padding between that top order
and the actual content inside.
So for all functional
purposes, these
provide the same
functional experience.
But this is just designed in a
slightly different way where it
has a real container around it.
It has a real header
to it in the sense
that it's got this
gray background holding
the tabs and the pills.
And you may have seen something
like this already with--
I believe in Shiny this
is called navlistPanel.
But I'm now calling
it navs_pill_list.
And there might be--
like, in the future,
there might be other different
variants that render things
in slightly different ways.
But this is more of
a sidebar approach
where you can get those
nav_items stacked vertically
and then the content
on the right.
And actually, these
functions are now
used by Shiny
underneath the hood when
you use tabPanel or navbarPage.
So now, the actual logic
for all of that stuff
lives inside of bslib.
But we've also built out the API
to allow you to do more with it
and design this functional
interface to allow
us to continue building more
ways to render navigation
items essentially.
[MUSIC PLAYING]